[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas nuestra
exposición france24 para analizar la
actualidad de la copa américa y la
eurocopa los estaremos acompañando a lo
largo de todo el desarrollo de estas
competiciones
estos son los titulares
francia debuta en la euro ante alemania
y en un hecho los campeones del mundo
integran el denominado grupo de la
muerte también con la portugal de
cristiano ronaldo vigentes campeones en
la selección de hungría tenemos informe
desde parís
y polémica en españa después del debut
con empate ante suecia las miradas están
sobre el delantero álvaro morata a sus
compañeros lo defienden y critican los
pitidos de los aficionados en el estadio
de sevilla
arquette y argentina empató ante chile
su estreno en la copa américa y paraguay
comenzó con goleada analizamos la
primera fecha de la copa cómo van los
favoritos
vamos a empezar hablando del grupo de la
muerte en la eurocopa pero antes es un
placer para mí saludar a nuestra
invitada en estudio sala castro
directora del diario 'as' hola juan un
gusto como siempre estar con ustedes así
es y se abre entonces este grupo efe en
una jornada esperada por muchos ahora
mismo esta juego el partido entre
hungría portugal estos últimos campeones
defensores minutos 55 empate a 0 en la
segunda parte más adelante duelo estelar
entre francia y alemania es por eso que
vamos a parís con nuestra periodista
erika olavarría quien nos cuenta cómo
viven los campeones del mundo este debut
en la euro con la confianza de ser los
actuales subcampeones de europa desde el
2016 y campeones del mundo desde rusia
2018 así llegan los franceses esta noche
a su estreno en esta eurocopa 2021 en
múnich frente a la dueña de casa
alemania los fanáticos se sienten
favoritos y así lo hacen sentir en
medios de comunicación en redes sociales
e incluso en el país el vecino
los galos cuentan con un mediocampo y
con una defensa muy sólido y además con
una delantera de miedo formada por
embate
y man y a la que se suma el hijo pródigo
karim benzema que regresa para demostrar
al mundo lo que ya saben en madrid' que
es un goleador de talla internacional
pero francia no ha tenido suerte ha
caído en el grupo de la muerte frente a
alemania un país que viene con sed de
venganza después de haber sido eliminada
en la primera ronda del mundial de
fútbol de rusia 2018 debe enfrentarse
también a hungría y a portugal que
cuenta además de cristiano ronaldo con
toda una nueva generación de jugadores
que se está luciendo en los campeonatos
europeos
para una francia que como decimos viene
con un cartel de favorita se enfrenta a
una alemania un poco en un proceso de
reconversión un poco hay una ligera
ventaja digamos a priori frente para los
franceses por supuesto pues hablamos del
vigente campeón del mundo pero sobre
todo un duelo de escuelas de fútbol no
hablamos de una francia que con de
champs logró ese campeonato y que más
que a redefinir su favoritismo lo que
tiene que decidir en este momento es
cuánto va a durar su hegemonía en el
fútbol ya lo explicaban muy bien tiene
una delantera de lujo con mbappe
griezmann y benzema que regresa y por su
parte alemán ya que ellos apostaron por
un juego más elaborado pero que parece
que en este momento no cuenta con las
fichas para lograr poner esa idea sobre
todo sobre el campo de juego ya joaquim
lo anunció que esté su último torneo con
la selección alemana una selección
alemana que jamás había enfrentado en
francia- justamente en un gran torneo en
el 2016 fue triunfo para france en las
semifinales así que vamos a ver un
partido muy muy interesante porque de
todas formas esa edad
adn alemán sigue estando presente
alemanias de alemania eso es cierto y
qué podemos decir acerca de los
y ahora mismo están jugando portugal
vigente campeona y hungría que viene de
la repesca hablar de portugal es hablar
de cristiano ronaldo de un largo proceso
también con fernando santos al frente
del equipo incluso se dan el lujo de
dejar un gran jugador como joao félix en
el banco y hungría es la cultura del
fútbol son dos veces subcampeones del
mundo es hablar de puskas es decir es un
equipo que seguro a dar problemas lo
sabemos hasta el momento a 0-0 es un es
un equipo que seguramente va a intentar
pelear rasguñar puntos en este grupo de
la muerte entendiendo además que los
otros por ser grandes van a tener que
disputarse mucho esas participaciones en
este momento minuto 58 de partido
continúa el 0-0 entre hungría y portugal
poco sorprendente todavía ese resultado
la ar pelea un río a dar pelea el
técnico que es marco rossi además dice
que admira mucho al argentino marcelo
bielsa que con él descubrió el fútbol se
conocieron en américa de méxico así que
pasar un equipo interesante para ver
seguro que si seguimos hablando de la
eurocopa porque ayer el lunes debutó de
españa una de las favoritas para muchos
y empataron contra suecia en un partido
que dejó todas
miradas frente al delantero español
álvaro morata tuvo una ocasión clara fue
titular y fue un jugador incluso salió
pitado en el estadio de sevilla en la
cartuja por algunos aficionados
españoles si eso suele pasar con españa
y es que incluso jugando de local hay
parte de la hinchada que no acompaña al
equipo qué es lo que pasa con álvaro
morata es un jugador emocional es un
jugador que viéndole la cara uno se da
cuenta lo que está pensando y eso a
veces no es bueno en el fútbol él era
una oportunidad y es difícil que salga
de ese bache es importante ese
acompañamiento que está sintiendo del
grupo del equipo pero si hay que decir
que españa no empató ayer a causa de
álvaro morata tuvo una posición del 85
por ciento durante todo el partido
todo lo que suecia es pero muy atrás de
hacerlo de los espacios y ellos tampoco
encontraron la manera de romper esas
líneas de presión así que no es sólo
álvaro morata creo que luis enrique va a
tener que trabajar vimos eso sí un coque
muy importante siendo líder
en todas las alturas del terreno de
juego así que creo que españa tiene que
recomponer pero tiene muchas jóvenes
fichas y sobre todo muy interesante es
lo de pedrito
yo creo que fue de menos a más durante
el partido así que vamos a ver una
españa interesante también precisamente
ya oí pedir el jugador de 18 años que
debutó ayer en la eurocopa fue uno de
los que habló en rueda de prensa y
expresó así su malestar por esos pitidos
bueno yo creo que es mucho mejor jugar
cuando cuando la gente te aplaude que
cuando te pita yo quiero quedarme con
los aplausos de la gente que que nos
animó que yo creo que que nos va a
ayudar mucho más que quedarnos con los
malos escucha vamos a pedir jugador
canario con ese acento característico
pasamos a la copa américa porque ya
terminó la primera fecha del torneo y
vamos a repasar los encuentros de ayer
lunes argentina empató contra chile y en
la noche para web venció a bolivia por 3
a 1 vamos a hacer un balance entonces de
los favoritos a los que ya vimos en
acción entendiendo como favoritos a los
históricos a argentina a brasil y
uruguay bueno de brasil hay que decir
que ganó cómodamente ante un venezuela
absolutamente diezmado lo hemos repetido
en diversas oportunidades el cob y por
supuesto los puso a armar un equipo casi
que desde cero pero si lo mostró digamos
un gran despliegue del juego pero sí sin
duda es el gran candidato porque tiene
un gran proceso con tite y porque ha
demostrado además que en ataque sin
mucho puede ser muy efectivo y en
defensa no tiene ningún inconveniente
habla ahora seguimos con argentina
argentina ayer tuvo un primer tiempo
interesante y lo interesante más allá
del golazo de lionel messi es que está
logrando una estructura en la que él no
es indispensable en todos los momentos
del partido y eso es fundamental sin
embargo el equipo se le cayó en el
escalón y tiene unos baches anímicos que
le cuestan como le costó ayer el empate
en un penal y luego la imposibilidad de
volverse a ir arriba en el marcador
lionel scaloni todavía con bastante
trabajo pero lo mismo fichas
interesantes con las cuales trabajar en
las segundas partes hemos visto si en
las segundas partes le cuesta mucho
mantener esa mentalidad parece que la
idea no convence y no logran mantener el
ritmo durante los 90 minutos insisto que
messi no es no necesita estar pendiente
en todas las zonas del partido eso es
importante porque no pueden ser más
independientes creo que se necesita que
messi también empiece sobre toda vez
equilibrar siendo como una ficha fuera
del sistema no llegando más o menos a
sorprender
chile también que viene una especie de
reconversión también tenemos que hablar
acerca de otros países que podemos decir
que estuvieran trofeo colombia-chile
efectivamente y perú a la que tampoco
hemos visto y uruguay tampoco lo hemos
visto claro uruguay nos falta por verlo
en este primer grupo de favoritos y
hablando de chile de colombia colombia
creo que logró un triunfo poco cómodo
pero muy importante empezar ganando por
lo que significa acercarse a la
clasificación creo que lo que ha hecho
rueda es tener un equipo sólido
defensivamente muy solidario sobre todo
y eso es fundamental
ha logrado ser efectivo vimos fantasia
en ese gol de edwin cardona y eso
también es importante chile chile
empieza un proceso con martín lasarte
creo que lo que ha conseguido es muy
importante porque ha demostrado que en
un equipo sin alexis ante su gran figura
también puede tener variantes y por
momentos complicó mucho a argentina y
estamos muy pendientes de ver a perú que
además está también en el grupo en la
zona de la selección de colombia con
chile vimos algo que también hemos visto
con colombia que están aprovechando para
hacer muchos cambios y hacer eso que
dice rueda de probar con varios equipos
porque pasan cuatro de cinco entonces se
lo pueden permitir en esta primera fase
y lo hemos dicho aquí en esta como
américa vamos a ir mucho de eso de
ajustar probar comprobar y examinar
variantes porque son equipos grandes que
van a intentar es sobre todo de sostener
un equipo muy ajustado de cara a qatar
así es esta copa américa aquí tiene de
momento ese pequeño descanso de dos
jornadas y antes de terminar repasemos
otras noticias de la eurocopa y la copa
américa comenzamos hablando de la
selección colombia porque el jugador
frank fabra ha sido convocado del que
abandona la concentración es el cairo
moreno que tiene una lesión muscular
ahora es el segundo jugador de boca
juniors que se integra al combinado el
cafetero junto con edwin cardona
el danés christian eriksen publicó en
redes sociales la primera foto desde su
desvanecimiento del fin de semana en el
partido ante finlandia estoy bien en
medio de las circunstancias dice el
jugador del inter desde la cama del
hospital
y la uefa abrió un expediente
disciplinario al jugador austríaco marko
arnautovic después de que el macedonio
del norte hiciera un llamado a revisar
las palabras del delantero en el duelo
de ambas naciones del domingo macedonia
asegura que arnautovic de origen serbio
se dirigió a elián y olías que de raíces
alemanas
minuto 64 de partido continúa el empate
entre hungría y portugal queda media
hora del partido empezará muchísimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros en
este espacio
un placer yo creo que van a venir
jornadas aún más interesantes equipos
más consolidados y así que vamos a vivir
una temporada magnífica ya ustedes como
no muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado en diario del copa le
recordamos lo vamos a acompañar durante
todo el desempeño de estos torneos que
desee porque además mucho más en france
24 me france24 puntocom
y